e sem mais delongas se o que faz demorar
gravar umas delongas
o mano aqui na Chica dos meus fã clube
Eu tenho um fã viu tem um fã queima é o
like Ai que botei menino voltou o
homem-aranha o tomar banho tomar banho
uma vou toma Ai que próprio uma aranha
vai te ensinar para o menino Homem
Aranha como é ser Homem Aranha chegou
dizer que eu fiz você não que passou tô
Maguary Maguary mesmo se eu tivesse o
nome de magoar aí eu ia tirar onda meu
passado ele ficar bom agora que
tem Tornei a volta do que não foi já
indo para a estrada bem saúde é que tem
show que eu vou falar já faz muito tempo
mano não sei mais fazer propaganda de
show dia 27 de novembro eu estou em
Brasília Olha só onde no Nilson Nelson
como sempre dia onze de dezembro vou
estar em Manaus Amazon que provavelmente
o maior show da minha vida até hoje mas
não é o meu irmão na alça Manaus Manaus
Manaus alguém presente Olha o presente
que eu ganhei no cara de Manaus
bonequinho York artista artista artista
que é artista o cara faz Realismo
realismo oi oi minha cara ela que o
batismo eu percebi que se o cabo é
realista mesmo fez eu até que depressão
não é nada bichinho o filho dele o Leon
brincadeira Tô brincando é brincadeira
mais bonito eu gosto é um dos que eu
mais gosto do que tem aqui na minha casa
e eu ganhei em Manaus
está brincando é brincadeira último dia
depois do dia que é o show em Manaus que
é dia onze no caso seria 12 deixou em
Goiânia Goiás
no dia Dezoito de dezembro nós estamos
em Florianópolis Santa Catarina de
último show do ano dia Dezenove de
dezembro no Rio de Janeiro que nesse
Arena para vocês terminarem sorrindo diz
cá passar e para o mundo para o Natal
para o aluno às vezes até
agora sem mais delongas como eu digo a
10 longas é que faz demorar são as
redondas mas antes de começar o vídeo eu
quero ver pera aí mano peraí fazer
direito mais enrolação toda a gente
começa o nem pedir um like ainda como é
que já quer que eu vi que vai começar
você não pedi nenhum like ainda mano só
que o João pediu maneira diferente né
porque as coisas mudaram sem tu não vem
aqui agora tô parecendo um Detento teu
irmão primeira vez que vinha tatuagem eu
morrendo de Feliz dois meses que eu tava
indo psiquiatra eu posso meu irmão Ei
mano tô de boa tô feliz amar consegui
sair da ônibus da cadeia na Nicarágua
Beleza vou pedir like né Sem Mais
delongas vou pedir ao MD chefe que ele é
o rei Lacoste quem é rei a gente tem que
obedecer soberania real do rei que a
gente gosta o requerente não gosta a
gente não obedece não cara papo reto
coisa disso quero discutir com você tudo
que não gostava porque a gente tava
andando com a tropa depois eu tava só
preciso do seu like ficar gostei para
ver você vai ser abençoado por na minha
mesa é um Hype ai ter a ela que ela
Laura Mury o Pandora
vamos nessa parte que susto ai meu deus
do céu foi sua maioria no banheiro ali
que se tinha tomado café cuspir saiu o
negócio da minha boca eu farei o que
susto meu amigo eu ia buscar eu tô com
os irmãos meu deu uma eu nem bebo estão
botando bebida em mim enquanto eu durmo
Paraná da cabeça da pessoa já tava
pensando tava injetando que tocou que
resfriado Eu odeio ficar e colocar mais
torrado ficar doente aqui aparece os
médios todo mundo é médico ao seu redor
tossir ficha a imunidade viu é baixou a
imunidade é essa é própolis só tá pronto
na garganta que duas coisas que o
pseudomédico gosta de diagnosticar
baixou a imunidade e foto de glicose aí
minha pressão caiu deixe glicose eu bota
a balinha na boca dela que a glicose
tudo no meio da Villa Mix como se
resolve com própolis e comelli esses
dias eu estava me lembrando a escola
aqui em casa né porque eu troquei de e
eu tava trazendo os livros para cá para
poder para que para decorar porque não é
mesmo eu não Lia muito meu negócio ali
que eu li a rótulo de xampu eu li até
aquele modo de usado para chegar nos
dois pontos vão saber como é que usar um
shampoo Elseve palavras literária assim
não entendi só que eu não tinha muita
esse hábito assim para falar a verdade
muitas escolas fazia as pessoas lerem
livro Iracema Dom Casmurro Memórias
Póstumas de Brás Cubas O Cortiço os
romances sempre os românticos um cabo
pegar alguém entrar de uma árvore e a
mulher era casada com o rapaz da Carroça
ali sem boa viagem de enfim eu ligo que
facilmente que seja resolvido se tivesse
um Villa Mix nem cabia lá tomava um
fazer o que tinha que fazer passava o
livro inteiro quero comer alguém atrás
de uma árvore acolá que sempre assim
dentro de um barco não a parada assim
nas escolas dos meus amigos né que já
tinha uma condição porque na minha
escola ninguém mandava ler livro nenhum
Até porque não tem como você exigir de
uma pessoa que ela não sabe aonde se
constrói um prédio tem como não tenho
conhecimento para esse também uma forma
ela lá porque ali não estava na oitava
série primeiro ano da tia gente que tava
aprendendo a ler e até amigo da escola
que pensa que eu bloqueei ele no
WhatsApp porque ele pesquisa meu nome e
pesquisa que tem na agenda dele o número
para lá para ele não chega a tá ele
porque ele escreve ruim deixa eu falar
que com i.a. e vá não é o rádio Agora
sim o terror a vida dos meus primos que
estudava na escola particular porque e
as costas do bichinho que ele levava
muito livro uma bolsa era
desproporcional faz o corte da criança
criança chega ficava pequena a vida
todinha Mas pode passar a escola
particular quando ele sai da escola é
estica mais escreve fala que vai fingir
couro meu filho agindo contra a
gravidade a vida inteira como é que traz
uma puxando para baixo mão dele não
adianta Só obter um conhecimento do
livro e não entendendo por trago esse
próprio que esse aprendendo a ciência
que a gravidade puxa para baixo um do
Lógico que eu vou serrar preste atenção
que o Pará que a gente poder ele pula
ele não tá despencando ele tá sendo
puxar Por isso que eu digo muitas vezes
a vivência ele dá mais entendimento da
própria física do que a aula de física é
do ver esse menino do interior que
segura na beirada do caminhão e vai nele
e depois ele sai do caminhão ele pula
ele ele não morre porque o conhecimento
da vivência me
gorro ele não sabe qual é o x no valor
ele não sabe qual o valor do X e o qual
o cálculo da parábola que ele tem que
fazer mas ele sabe que você falar do
jeito errado e capota é assim a vida da
pessoa da escola particular ele tem um
livro ele tem que comprar mais livre tem
que levar todos e não levo não para ver
como é que não é na escola escola É não
meu amigo escola pública amanhã a gente
aprende a viver Quando você viaja de
férias você leva a sua casa amigo não
você leva o que albasu falando da escola
pública se hoje tem aula de que
português história geografia matemática
e fiz Ixi geografia levou Grosso ah não
vai foi mal a geografia foi mal foi mal
já tô ligado já tô ligado onde é Macapá
física Vista eu vou voltar para casa de
pedra garota do caminhão Mas por que
pegar o fio matemática eu vou levar
aquela eu tô levando físico também não
posso excluir os números da minha vida
ela acho que vou levar só de história e
chegar na escola para 5 horas um livro
Só que era de História porque o
professor de história gosto de botar
para ler ele não só gosta de botar falei
para ele gosta de pegar no flagra como
em português Eu desconfio que ele se ele
sai juntos de histórico de Português o
aluno tá valendo né o Tratado de
Tordesilhas o Tratado de Tordesilhas
assinado na povoação castelhana de
Tordesilhas em 7 de junho de 1494 em um
tratado celebrado entre isso é um aluno
que ele né porque tem um aluno que
professor fala assim vamos começar a
leitura ele tá bom Mas tu sabe mesmo a
Parabéns Mas beleza nós aí ela e já fica
nervoso com medo de lembrar que tinha
trabalho porque esses meninos que querem
rápida se ele leva de tudo é teu reino
de Portugal EA coroa de Castela para
dividir as terras descobertas e por
descobrir' e tu batendo papo com o teu
amigo baixinho né louca galera que
assisti [ __ ] de madrugada e não tinha
internet para assistir na Band para
baixar o volume deixar no mínimo ficar
vendo o povo transar e SMS tô
conversando com teu amigo é
o Whindersson continua
meu amigo a hora que o coração bate na
cabeça que você sente Acabei de fazer
assim ó um
é isso aqui não é perdi aí tu vai
tentando ler adivinhando que tu vai
lendo meio de um pedacinho de parágrafo
por parágrafo e o professor vai fazer
aquela cara de tá quente tá frio tá
quente tá frio esse tratados vários
viagens de Cristo tratado definidos o
essa linha estava um amigo teu do lado
crente salvassem da Bandeira foi assim ó
e com o dedo em cima do lugar para
começar sem fazer contato visual com o
professor e tudo no do lado português
esses salva quase achando lugar o
[ __ ] lá do fundo 108 Pronto
legitimou agora o professor ficar
reclamando comigo toda hora presta ela
tava quase achando mano tá na página 16
você só o Whindersson Jorge fora
da salinha para o banheiro nessa saída
da sala que você dizia para si mesmo que
tipo de pessoa você seria para o resto
da vida é a maneira como você sai da
sala depois que o professor bota você
para fora diz muito sobre quem você é
nas adversidades da vida porque elas vão
vir aquele podia tanto me derrubar o que
eu faço eu choro e não dá para perder
para o mundo junto a cadeira de sair da
sala não pode você é um cara violento o
cara agressivo não tá é de peito erguido
nem mexer a galera era para mim falar
ele é o rappi É isso aí é um Hype irmã
Ela olhava para mim dizer assim ele vai
fazer grandes coisas isso e no processo
de leitura Vamos se ver como realmente o
processo e leitura até sem ler ele tem
uma importância muito grande nos graus
científico da criação cerebral e dizer
uma palavra mais complexa assim mas
cerebral é massa qual cerebral cerebral
mas até raiva a gente falar não gosta de
ler exatamente por isso tem que levar o
livro já tá ultrapassado que tu tu pá pá
pá pá pá Ei mano tem gente que é da dia
e tem gente que é do noite tem gente que
dorme de dia e fica acordado a noite e
tem gente que dorme a noite acordada dia
como é o caso do uso asiáticas Enquanto
aqui a gente tá estão tem um tímido que
negócio para você ler como fosse o livro
é com seu pai fala até assim se quiserem
é pequenininho assim como se fosse um
livro vários livros dentro de um
aparelhinho aí você você passa a página
até acima as pode fazer até assim e
passar não sei se presta mesmo que um
livro Só que demore aí uns 500 anos para
se decompor mas não cortar água entendeu
E assim a gente vai levando a mão sempre
tentando não prejudicar ninguém
prejudicando porque ela tem como para
construir alguma coisa tem que destruir
outra eu gosto mudou muito depois que eu
comer quem tem esse tipo show era as
pessoas chegarem para mim falar assim eu
nunca tinha ido ao teatro cara isso é
pouco a gente tomar É muita gente que me
fala isso é muita gente também tem muita
gente ao meu redor são muito famoso Ai
me lembrei que hora que eu esqueço É
muita gente que chega assim fala assim
cara eu tô aqui na tua frente é
interessante porque tu já me fez mijar
de rima é muito interessante está aqui
na tua frente agora eu peço a pessoa que
ela vai no show muitas vezes pela
primeira vez é uma sensação irmão
imaginava do que a sinergia é muito [ __ ]
já vou rodar o Brasil fazendo show pela
oitava vez mais então tipo assim muita
gente foi para o Teatro pela primeira
vez e tem uma coisa que eu queria que
você fizesse pela primeira vez mais uma
vez para você que assim como eu não
tenho costume de ler mas precisa começar
a ler porque eu recebi esse conselho de
pessoas sensacionais de nascimentos você
é um cara muito inteligente maduro para
sua idade se você lê se você ia ficar
melhor ainda e eu não quero começar essa
jornada sozinha eu quero que vocês
também começa leitores assim como vocês
começaram a frequentar o teatro por
minha causa e depois do show começou a
ir em vários shows em show de comédia em
show de teatro mesmo eu quero apresentar
pra vocês o meu livro e vendo como um
guerreiro que já está disponível para
pré-venda no link na descrição desse
vídeo tá desse livro em colaboração com
o escritor Gabriel Chalita tem minha
história e conversas É como se eu
conversasse sobre vários assuntos
diferentes foi esse cara e ele me
entendesse me compreendesse colocasse em
palavras de escritor para falar a
verdade que eu não sou um escritor posso
ser o autor o que criei mas não sou
escritor escritor o nosso príncipe
Gabriel Chalita esse livro tá muito
lindo é um livro de leitura rápida eu
conto sobre meus amigos sobre a minha
família sobre minha vindas muita coisa
mas dia seis de dezembro Ele tá em todas
as livrarias aí do Brasil mas por
enquanto ele já tá vendendo no site se
você quiser já comprar o seu já pode aí
na pré-venda o link que está aí eu tenho
um livro mas como é que pode é eu na
capa dele é muito legal O livro é
dividido em conversa só 15ª conversa Olá
meus amigos que me sustentaram até aqui
que é isso eu espero que você tenha
gostado deste vídeo de hoje não esquece
de clicar em gostei se esse vídeo tiver
muito gostei e próximo vídeo eu entro
dançando agora você vai clicar né óbvia